good morning and welcome to the Columbia
University world leaders forum by
bringing us in direct contact with
global policy makers and heads of state
this forum allows us to better
understand some of the most urgent
matters that all of us care about and
ultimately have the responsibility to
help resolve it is an ideal way to start
the new academic year and we are
grateful to all of those who have helped
us in presenting these world leaders at
Columbia this fall before the week is
over we will have had the privilege of
hearing speeches from the leaders of
Ghana Columbia Mauritius Austria and
Nepal and others this morning our
distinguished guest is Doris loitered
president of the Swiss Confederation
before introducing the president I want
to recognize the ambassador and Consul
General Andre shalour and all the other
members of the Swiss delegation thank
you and welcome here Switzerland's
president is selected by the members of
the Swiss Federal Council who choose one
of their peers miss loitered has
received that honor twice first in 2010
and again in 2006 and 17 she entered
government as the as a member of
parliament and later during her time on
the council she served as head of the
Department of Economic Affairs and
continues to oversee the Department of
Environment transport energy and
communications as will be evident from
her remarks this morning the president
is an accomplished attorney and legal
scholar she received her law degree from
the University of Zurich
notwithstanding its distinctive history
and culture and its long-standing
commitment to neutrality the challenges
confronting Switzerland are very much
the product of this particular moment
and the currents of our global society
Switzerland is in the process of
increasing the transparency of its
banking system trying to overhaul the
nation's corporate tax system and
navigating issues such as mass migration
and the future of the European Union
that are buffeting its neighbors and
that hold the potential to change the
face and identity of Europe the country
approaches these issues with the
political system infused with an unusual
degree of democracy
well most laws are drafted and decided
upon by Parliament there is a process by
which individual the citizens may put
those laws to a general vote or when
appropriate propose amendments to the
Constitution Switzerland has also earned
a reputation for being an especially
adept mediator of international conflict
with a willingness to shoulder its
weight and much more in the shared
global effort to spread peace from civil
wars in Burundi and Nepal to more
recently the Colombian conflict
involving FARC Switzerland has been
involved in negotiations that have
helped bring an end to armed conflict
repeatedly Switzerland has chosen to act
as an engaged in responsible citizen
among the community of nations in
keeping with this proud tradition of
international engagement President
loitered recently offered the services
of her nation to help address the North
Korean crisis an offer that has
refocused attention on the president and
her nation Madam President we are all
eager to have you here with us this
morning hear what you have to say please
join me now in welcoming the president
of the Swiss Confederation doris
loitered
[Applause]
well mr. president ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the Swiss government I'd
like to thank you for your kind
invitation and I'm very happy that we
can together past an hour and discuss
about the rules of law the situation of
of the planet I'm very pleased that I
can be at a very famous University
because it's always important to have
this exchange with students and to have
a dialogue and also an understanding
from students what we in policy politics
are doing what we prepare because you as
future leaders will have the solutions
we did not find or perhaps we find
solutions you can then implement so it's
very important that we have this contact
and I'm very happy that I can be with
you this morning and thank you again is
the president for the invitation the
rule of law or the law of the channel
for the United States and the Swiss
Confederation sisters republics the
answer is very clear there needs to be
rule of law but national law can only
apply for all if it is embedded in a
global set of rules and is thus
applicable to all a state that abides by
international law is not a weak state a
state that upholds international law
helps the weak and gains in strength
itself as a result Switzerland is a
comparatively small neutral country is
not part of any military alliance and it
has a highly developed economy can
research center it has an alpine
territory particularly close to the
impact of climate change but on our own
we can either protect our alts nor our
people just as no states can pursue
economic policy on its own we are
dependent on a set of reliable global
rules even the u.s. as a superpower with
its outstanding universities and great
innovations is an integral part of the
global whole and needs a set of
international rules regardless of
whether country is large or small all
have an interest in seeing that
international law is applied there may
be a few states dotted around the globe
right now that believe themselves to be
the strongest today we are witnessing a
period of far-reaching geopolitical and
economic change similar to that seen at
the time of the birth of our two sister
republics it is characterized by
interdependence and globalization and a
regional and vertical shift of wealth
the impact of the digital revolution is
transnational the potential impact on
the value-added chain the labor markets
the way we exchange and process
information on influence and power on
sovereignty and dependence are huge we
can already feel the effects of all that
today the positive and the negative the
impact of climate change migration and
terrorism can also be felt
internationally this phenomena give rise
to fear because they exceeds the
individual sphere of influence and this
it is precisely because we are
increasingly faced with such
developments because the individual is
increasingly unable to
influence these changes themselves that
we need international law and that's
once again you're here in New York at
the UN conference to talk about
international law changes are manifested
in original and vertical shifting valve
on the one hand the world is better off
now than it was 30 years ago globally
the number of people living in extreme
poverty has halved since the 1990s
maternal mortality rate has been
significantly reduced access to primary
education access to electricity access
to power has drastically increased the
international community has set a course
to further improve the livelihood of
people around the globe by committing to
the sustainable development goals
sustainable development girls who are a
new international regulation which now
has a national level be introduced on
the water on the other hands however the
middle class is in the highly developed
West find themselves squeezed many
developed countries have experienced a
decrease in the size of their middle
class and in the share of total income
going to the middle class many citizens
in the West increasingly identify
globalization as the cause for the
growing squeeze on wages the pressure to
perform and to perceive decline of their
country's prosperity in response
political forces increasingly pushed the
demand for greater national sovereignty
sometimes explicitly as a rejection of
the international legal order but it is
possible to see that tangents between
that development that I've mentioned
manifests themselves across the board
globally nationally and the lives of
each and every one of us politically
social economically and culturally
that's not a theory it's reality all too
often the solution that emerges is
nationalism and populism and
economically protectionism this
phenomenon feed on a variety of sources
and you have to be aware of this as an
urge to withdraw in the face of the
boundaries lost through globalization as
a rejection of open tolerant social
models as a strategy of to answer
citizens justified expectations of their
governments to safeguard prosperity and
living standards in a continually
changing context in other words as an
instrument to safeguard power on a
domestic level and as a way of
strengthening international influence
the Hartford consensus on the validity
of international laws and convention is
coming on the pressure the more
fractured this international consensus
becomes the greater to appeal to resort
to national solutions the more populous
the nationalists the agenda becomes the
greater the interest in seeing the
collapse of international consensus will
be and the greater the risk will be that
the rule of the most powerful wins out
ladies and gentlemen
international law is not a pick and
choose stands where it can just take
what you want and leave the rest
international law is binding it was
negotiated it was signed and it was
ratified on the basis of its tradition
and as a host state of humanitarian
Geneva so international humanitarian law
my country is particularly attached to
one body of international law
international humanitarian law its aim
is to preserve a minimum of humanity in
world I am appalled at all one of the
greatest achievements of the modern
global community international
humanitarian law is increasingly being
systematically violated you can see in
most of the conflicts that this law
which was negotiated is very often
violated the main challenge at the
moment is to improve respect for this
body of law and to prevent its
credibility from being steadily
undermined mastering this challenge is
one of the priorities of Switzerland's
foreign policy and because we insist on
this humanitarian law we have a role
also to raise the flag wherever on the
planet this international humanitarian
law is violated we raise our flag also
to say you can't solve these conflicts
by violating law and by normally by
armed conflicts we have to solve this by
dialogue that's also we offer our good
services in a lot of conflicts or we
offer our services that countries find a
platform to communicate for example
between Georgia and Russia we have been
helpful in the Syrian conflict with a
lot of dialogue in Geneva or we defend
in Iran the interests of the United
States because it's much more easier to
pass through Swiss diplomatic
to talk and communicate with each other
international law is not just being
violated it is also being eroded this
often occurs insidiously the principle
of the universality of human rights is a
cornerstone of international
humanitarian law and has been reiterated
in numerous conventions declarations and
resolutions and yet not only is this
principle being questions more and more
openly the term human rights itself has
come to stand in competition with terms
such as human values however the two
terms are not interchangeable values are
not the same as rights and what values
are intended to guide us rights and the
protection of those rights are binding
or in other words even those who
disregard values are entitled to have
their fundamental human rights protected
it is dangerous if we start to water
down the meaning of language in
international discussions and with
regard to international law and it will
be a challenge to reach a common
understanding of those concepts in
seeking to address global challenges I
will cite the example of infrastructure
which embodies globalization like no
other the Internet of the digital
environment we have to give through to
how this digital environment is governed
but but what does that mean exactly does
this mean the autonomous certainty of
the digital environment independent from
national or international law or do we
mean the opposite namely sovereignty on
the soft state in defining modalities of
control over the digital in
Harmon and what does this larger form of
sovereignty aim to achieve I'm sure as a
university you know all these questions
and you can help us to find solutions so
far there is no one
we began discussions and we will discuss
in December at the Internet Governance
forum in Geneva with a lot of
specialists but you have to solve these
issues to suppress criticism to protect
domestic businesses or to protect in the
sense of data and privacy or to fight
against cyber criminality well the
international community governments the
private sector and civil society have to
reach some kind of agreement
this discussion is crucial and the free
press and free minds must be allowed to
contribute to a solution
ladies and gentlemen
changes reflected in the shaping of the
International order its institutions
mechanisms and conventions reforms are
needed at the UN and at various other
international organizations they were
mostly created after the second world
war and today we have to adapt reality
with the governance of these
organizations international sets of
rules need to be developed further
non-state actors need to be included in
the search for solutions as well as
scientists over the last 10 to 15 years
multilateral sets of rules have not been
very successful I remember 10 years ago
I passed my whole summer in Geneva at
the WTO Doha conference a lot of
discussions but finally two members
disagreed so the solution the Doha round
many efforts at reform are going round
in circles which makes the conclusion of
agenda 2030 the Paris climate agreement
or the UN resolution on sustainable
peace all the more important it shows
also it's still possible to have new
universally agreed regulation un
secretary-general Gutierrez is actively
pursuing reform of the UN system in
three areas first peace and security
second development and third management
together the UN twords addressing
current and future challenges challenges
Switzerland is very active in these
processes and tries also here to
moderate between the different interest
different actors and to find as fast as
possible solutions there is a need to
implement and further develop
international bodies of law governance
structures and working mechanisms need
to reflect present realities we have new
powers we have a shift of power also
towards Asia we have a lot of NGOs also
these voices must be reflected in the
new structures we also have to recognize
that global actors launched their own
initiatives to set up international or
supranational organizations and forums
that is to be welcomed as it places
responsibility on those actors but there
has to be a way of ensuring that such
forums accept international rules and
conventions and we always have to ask
ourselves whether and to what extent
these bodies enjoy legitimacy respect
for international law and its promotion
have always been a high priority
of Swiss foreign policy we do this out
of the conviction that international law
and its bodies provide a basis for peace
for stability and the protection of
human beings but we also do it out of
bare necessity Switzerland is one of the
most globalized nations in the world one
of the most open countries and together
with the u.s. normally we are also
ranked on the most innovative countries
all over the world and this openness
working together with others is part of
this success story our economy is
strongly driven by exporting industries
of both goods and services access to
markets as well as compliance with
international trade regimes and rules by
all partners are fundamental it gives
our economy a solid base and you know
also your partner is relying on
international rules Switzerland is the
seventh largest financial center in the
world and we as a small country are also
investing a lot in United States we are
ranked number six as investor in the US
quite surprisingly for a small country
but it shows when you have good partners
we share the rules of law which are open
economies this drives the economy this
also is attractive for young people for
new solutions new companies new ideas
Switzerland has therefore an interest in
stable global financial architecture and
in transparency of financial flows this
is why Switzerland actively participated
in the framework of the OECD Global
Forum on transparency and exchange of
information for tax purposes we would
like to see this also in some
Aaron states increasing it ensures that
the international standards regarding
transparency and exchange of information
are complied with and are implemented in
a uniform manner internationally
Switzerland is particularly vulnerable
when it comes to climate change
perhaps afield well as a landlocked
country there's no reason to be affected
but as I mentioned our alts are
extremely vulnerable we have double
global warming in our hopes then in
their world average over the last 150
years the average temperature in my
country has risen by two degrees Celsius
that is more than twice the global
average although our per capita
emissions are very low we are dependent
on the measures of all states it is
vital therefore that the Paris agreement
is implemented as you know Switzerland
is a neutral country neutrality is
defined under international law with
rights and with obligations of a neutral
state that is part of our tradition of
good services good offices and
humanitarian aid neutrality does not
apply to military operations authorized
by the UN Security Council for the
latter is acting under a mandate from
the community of states in order to
re-establish peace and international
security nor does the law of neutrality
prevent neutral States from supporting
such operations that you have we are
engaged in all these UN peacekeeping
missions it is of course from the mantle
to Switzerland
our neutrality is internationally
recognized and respected but it is a
fundamental to our interest that UN
system works and the Security Council
remains capable and credible in its
decision-making and finally it is also
fundamental that international
conventions are respected I mentioned
ladies and gentlemen our particular
attachments for international
humanitarian law I also mentioned that
the main challenge consists in improving
respect for IHL not in reforming it
indeed the basic tenets of ITIL are
timeless to not harm civilians to not
harm civilians was once agreed was once
the DNA of many countries treat
prisoners humanely treat prisoners
humanely do not use excessive force care
about the sick and wounded minimize the
cruelty of war there is however
something missing in IHL a genuine
dialogue dialogue is an essential
ingredient for respect surprisingly the
Geneva Conventions enter additional
protocols did not provide for such a
regular dialogue among states at the
global level Switzerland has therefore
been working with the International
Committee of the Red Cross on bringing
to life a forum of states dedicated to
the implementation of IHL a large
majority of states is deeply committed
to the idea so are we
ladies and gentlemen our interests as an
open globalised rules-based and
democratic nation are best protected and
promoted in the framework of respected
international rules based on agreed
standards enshrined in international law
I am certain that in view of
globalization geopolitical and
geo-economic changes respect for
international law and credible
transparent and accountable
international organizations are udderly
in Switzerland core interests but in the
interests of all of us you as young
leaders of tomorrow will have to work
that these international rules are again
the pillar of peace the peace for to
protect a lot of human beings and to
protect the planet try to help us that
the rule space system all over the
planet is the DNA of the young leaders
of tomorrow thank you very much
[Applause]
so we can take questions and there are
two microphones I will call on you and
the president can respond but to begin
with I'll just ask a few questions Madam
President so on this thank you very much
for those remarks and I think this is an
audience certainly at this university
who feels very much aligned with what
you said this role of Switzerland in the
world of being a mediator neutral and
the like I think we're all interested in
how that is sustained in today's world
and the most recent instance that you've
identified where Switzerland is offering
to play this role is with respect to
North Korea could you say something
about why that's a credible offer I mean
any country could say we're ready to
help with solving the crisis with North
Korea but Switzerland has a kind of
special role in the world that makes
that interesting and attractive how does
that happen in that particular case and
reflecting more generally on the role of
Switzerland yesterday thank you for this
question I think er well we can profit
first that in Geneva we have most of
international organizations which are
present there so actually I can approach
all kind of sectoral issues in Geneva we
are a safe place we are a discreet place
when you meet in Geneva we can organize
this
that's no media really are present so a
lot of leaders are looking for a place
where you don't know they need and in
North Korea especially we have a special
role because for more than six years our
soldiers are at the border between North
and South Korea the demarcation line
together with Sweden we are present
present here for more than six years and
we are one of the few countries who have
humanitarian projects within North Korea
so this allows us to have an entry point
to also the political system where I
think we together with Norway we are
practically alone there and the
neutrality perhaps mr. president is the
last point we don't we don't have to
defend Western or Eastern interests we
are not a member of NATO so all these
elements create some kind of credibility
for us and it's not fair well we don't
know yet if the parties involved accept
our offers of good offices we know the
Foreign Ministry of China already had a
positive founder now we had the UN
sanction so we will follow its the offer
each year the partners know it and now
it must be discreet on the diplomats
whenever then they wish we are ready to
do this job very interesting I assume
that in the world of globalization and
the establishment of norms of openness
and so to some extent maintaining that
position of neutrality must be difficult
for Switzerland and some since I take
the banking system so you the the role
with North Korea in part is because
things can be done privately it doesn't
have to be under the glare of the media
spotlight neutrality demands a kind of
closure in a way I mean it to be
successful it's a good thing on the
other hand you want more and more
transparency in the world so the banking
system of Switzerland as we all know
from reading papers and so on is under
transformation how in the context of
Switzerland how is that position of
neutrality and what's needed to sustain
that it's self under pressure from
globalization I think for us it's two
totally different discussions we have
first at the beginning we did we did not
understand that when it comes your
private sphere the wish of many
countries is to be totally transparent
because well we still think your medical
details your engine theaters your bank
account that's actually part of your
private sphere okay international rules
are now different I think a lot of
transparency is needed so here we adapt
it I'm not so sure if all the
information you get out of all these
data is really helpful for human mankind
but we do it we have not not an issue
anymore
we are a violation was it chemical
weapons or what I mean do you feel that
there's a risk of other member states
potentially leaving and what do you feel
could be done in the next decade to
strengthen the EU as a whole I think
it's probably the opposite because now
you three breaks it is quite a challenge
and I think people begin to realize
perhaps it was not the best decision but
it is a decision you have to accept that
so I think well you see for the moment
among the EU members there's more
cooperation than before
that's although they are quite tough if
UK which might not be very very good for
all of us better you see more either you
a remember or you're out and there's no
in between
so even when
when you now is also going to have more
economic growth which is good for all of
us
they have to solve some issues and
probably one element of the British
result is also because they had one
crisis after the other one unsolved
challenged after after the other and
people recognized or Europe is losing
power and the influence and has one
crisis after the other so please are
stabilized and give us hope and the
future and I think today with president
macro with also young where presidents
who are Adam another view on Europe you
want to see more importance more
economic growth this can really turn the
page and give more cooperation and
stronger feeling we are together we want
to have our place in the world than we
had before and I'm pretty much sure that
Angela Merkel will be reelected so this
can be quite a powerful couple for the
next years thank you yes thank you very
much news regarding neutrality it is
beyond doubt that mediating between
conflicts it's crucial and that you play
a unique role in in the worlds fear of
politics but there are still several
many many cases of inevitable armed
conflicts that you will naturally unless
you go through the UN you don't get
involved in and my question is regarding
that your peculiar position of
combination of a tremendously powerful
economic and political country and at
the same time you yourself and your
party belonging to the Christian
Democratic Party of Switzerland how do
you accommodate the fact that you both
have the means and the principles to
involve yourselves in company those
conflicts when your foreign policy
prevents you from doing that well we
have our armed forces we have a strong
military
services we have also quite a huge
budget on that but it's more to prevent
ourself prevent Switzerland from our
neighbors you know after in the Second
World War we have been circled by Nazis
by fascist organizations so actually to
have in the army and these neutrality
helped us to survive and helped us also
to that you have a lot of refugees
coming to Switzerland we could protect
them and in these conflicts in these
armed conflicts we have pretty much the
same position being neutral allows us by
via diplomatic channels to work in the
background helps us via our humanitarian
aid to protect people who suffer from
this conflict and perhaps also here to
defend the international humanitarian
law this is not always easy we have all
also in an industry who produces arms so
this is also always a debater
is this balanced or that's why we are we
have a very restrictive regulation where
and to which country they can sell arms
so this is perhaps also an element we
chose it's not an easy position we take
our responsibility but we prefer always
peacekeeping process dialogue and not
being a part of armed conflict thank you
yes thank you madam president
you mentioned the collaboration between
government the private sector and civil
society or nongovernmental organizations
and I'm interested in your eyes what do
you think the role of civil society or
these NGOs is in upholding international
law or aiding in conflict resolution and
do you see that role
growing or even evolving in the coming
years as we experience these changing
times I think it's absolutely important
that we see such a lot of important
organizations having a voice in all
these difficult questions and I think
the role is increasing we've seen it for
example in the negotiation process of
the Paris agreement we will also have
today a panel on private sector
investments for STG so we need
definitely the private sector not only
for financing we need it for
technologies for innovation we need it
also because sometimes politicians have
not both to have four-year circle to to
overview but a company or NGOs have a
lot much longer view and wish and this
is very important so in Switzerland by
our direct democracy we have already
when we discuss a new law a high
influence of NGOs or civil organizations
they have the same rights like a
political party they have they're very
strong in lobbying for their interests
transparent way but I think it's very
important for us that's why I think that
my link to the governance of all these
international organizations we should
also think how we can structure this
influence and and and and bring them in
the in the political dialogue I think in
the u.s. it's pretty much the same
development like we see in Europe yes hi
you mentioned the the need for reform I
think the UN Security Council and of
course like the UN Security Council has
five permanent members like somehow
representing the global West and the
global East and they have
absolute veto power and there's been a
lot of criticism against this system
because it creates sort of like you know
the nuclear powers who get to strong-arm
the rest of the world but if I wasn't
sure if you were referring to reforming
like that part and also if that does
riff require reform how would you even
begin to change that set up because it's
and they like the five permanent members
of the nuclear weapons well I think
their reforms of to UN Security Council
is very crucial very political so for
many years we try to adapt a little bit
to see smell and I think most of you all
sometimes when one power declares his
veto we are not very pleased about that
but anyhow there's a discussion there's
also transparency who stands for what
and even perhaps when they don't decide
because of a veto there's a development
there's something who happens and
Switzerland for the moment is chairing
the Nuclear Suppliers group so here we
discussed if all the countries who have
nuclear weapons can be members even when
they are not part of the NPT so a
non-problem proliferation treaty and
what could be the consequences so we
think also here better to involve all
important partners and give some rules
some expectations what should happen is
better than to leave it to some
countries who discuss under themselves
and you know nuclear weapons for the
moment this is an issue and we must try
that
there's no overreaction that he can
stabilize also tensions and that's
typically what Switzerland tries to do
and I'm sorry to say that sometimes
there are some personalities some main
personalities which have the power so we
should have perhaps also some more
female who have another approach thank
you you have been talking about how
Switzerland is involved in peacemaking
however this is not the case with Egypt
I mean Switzerland supports the current
Authority in Egypt which is led by a
pathetic Sisi this general has been
killing youth in Egypt this general has
been detained in youth in Egypt and I
don't know I can't see where how such
event is bringing peace to Egypt by
supporting such such a dictator I mean I
have friends but supposed to be in such
universities but they're rotting in
prison I have friends who are supposed
to be in such an vs. but they're now
dead because of this man and this man is
actually attending the United Nations
and this man is actually participating
in putting was called a international
law so how can I believe in the United
Nations international law in
Switzerland's role and peacemaking while
you aro you're actually you know dealing
with this man who's he who know he he
let Egypt through a military coup after
all you you say that we are here for
democracy were here for elections and
all that stuff at FCC came you know
through a military coup after all thank
you madam president
I understand that you were it's
difficult for you to see this president
and how the situation of Egypt but we
accept also elections and many
presidents even if you don't like him
he's elected in a correct way then he's
to elect President and then we were
together with this government and they
have a lot of projects in Egypt on
democracy on the rules of
we try to get in our economy that they
create jobs for people and we try
whenever people are in prison or there's
no free expression of your of your bill
or journalists are in prison here we try
to help them and then it's better to
work with these presidents than against
his regime I'm sorry mister
I'm sorry mr. prison but this man wasn't
elected I think this could be debated
for a long time yes president who was
elected in 2012 he was supposed to end
this dream in 2016
he came in 2013 how was he elected
understand I understand you but you must
one country cannot tell another you must
now have again elections or the election
you had is not valuable anymore this is
a discussion except that's why we have
heared United Nations we have other
platforms but while the power is in
vigor in force we must talk with them
and they must try to do the best with
them not against them this is not
helpful thank you yes thank you
president Leath harsh for coming and
talking to us today I had a question um
you were saying earlier about the Swiss
Alps how they're so vulnerable to
climate change the years ahead and
especially the idea of climate change it
you know transcends boundaries national
boundaries it goes on to the
international level and he's wondering
especially in you know the UN talks this
week yesterday president
Miroslav Lu Jackie was talking the
cathedral about the oneness of the world
the peace is sustainable action and so
what do you really hope will be
accomplished especially hard to
sustainable development in the week
ahead at the UN talks and also are not
so political question do you
a favor Swiss writer The Laughing curved
STG and like the Paris agreement both
are for for me successful new agreements
and lower the implementation of all this
is crucial and as usually it's about
money it's about financing we will have
today panels on that we will have later
on this year how we can finance all the
needs to implement measures and to
support countries developing countries
who have not enough of public resources
and here that's private sector
engagement initiatives also from
academia because well a lot a lot of
technical solutions can be helpful so to
combine all this will be crucial in the
upcoming years and that's why I see not
enough which is some not enough ambition
but it goes in the right direction
we should really increase the speed of
implementing all these measures because
you see the impact of both is costs much
more than acting now and being ambitious
and I have with our writers for example
marching suture I don't know if you know
him but on the internet you can see
that's one of my favorites thank you
very much so we're almost out of time if
you could ask questions very briefly
each of you and then the president can
decide which one she wants to answer and
which one she will so let's go very
quickly please ask your question thank
you very much
earlier you spoke about imposing
sanctions on countries that
humanitarian and international law so
for some countries such as Russia which
the US has already imposed into economic
sanctions on thee seem to have little or
no effect so what other steps do you
propose to take for these countries for
which sanctions are not enough thank you
so let's take the other questions and go
ahead please
good morning I was just going to ask
because you mentioned the Paris
agreement and climate change have
Switzerland what is the core thing that
they're doing to tackle these issues and
how they can inspire other countries
States and organizations also to tackle
these issues so sanctions on
international humanitarian law
violations climate change yes next my
question is about technology so I know
you mentioned briefly about you know how
we live in a digital transformation or
digital disruption it's one or the other
it's how you perceive what is your
stance for Switzerland in the future on
implementing these new technologies I
think we better stop there and an answer
and we'll draw to a close
okay I begin with climate change er
again we are also in Switzerland vicious
on our goals although the Apple already
a very low level emissions per capita I
think here in the US you have four times
more or aversions more than we have but
you can improve the good news is you can
improve and that's a potential I think
it's almost a combination of technology
it's also new for example in in
transport I think you can improve quite
heavily here also if you look at your
buildings
standards or buildings there could be an
example so we I think we with a lot of
countries there's now a platform to
change best practices good ideas and
also find the financing for that so the
ideas would be here but it ups it's up
to do to every country now to implement
what seems to be available but
I think there's a lot of things going on
and now it's up to every country to
really now head forward your question
about sanctions again well Switzerland
had the presidency of the OECD so also
some kind of moderation between Ukraine
and Russia and the parties we had the
Minsk agreement actually a good solution
how the population and the powers who
develop the future it's not reached yet
it's not implemented yet so we still
hope that the conflict parties again
follow the road of the agreement of
Minsk and here you see Russia has a lot
of sanctions already and nothing happens
actually and therefore we have to also
think on other elements how we can how
we can find a way for the population who
lives in these areas because they are
everyday confronted with violence every
day they live in unstable situation you
have all over the world what more than 1
billion children who knows nothing but
violence and instability so I think
again here we must be creative and find
solutions
sometimes it's face-saving for the
leaders faithful in solution that that's
ok yes I can do and so here a lot of
fantasy and discussions to see why is it
not rational why is it so emotional and
here I think Switzerland are the
diplomats and others can try to find
such elements technology
yes for example FinTech when it comes to
financing it could be a powerful answer
also for countries like the African
continent who has not a lot of money but
we FinTech you have a lot of small
contributors who can make a change
technology when you see now also yes in
transport well a lot of people like to
have a car and when you new technologies
can help us that you can drive it we
don't want to have restrictions on your
personal mobility but you can do it more
smart that's the best way they can
improve and here I think Switzerland has
a very normative country as well as the
US have something to say and can work
together and this Moscow through
academia that's why we spend a lot of
money for our universities for you
because we think here are the brains who
can give us these answers we afterwards
as politicians can implement and try the
best that it's covering all our society
so I count on you the Madam President to
close with an endorsement of money
coming to universities Madam President
thank you very much for spending this
morning with and very illuminating we
really appreciate it thank you thank you
very much all the best
[Applause]